Європейські країни більше не купуватимуть золото та вироби з нього у Росії.
Це передбачає сьомий пакет санкцій ЄС. Дорогоцінний метал
більше не можна ввозити з Росії до Європи.
У Росії 8,5 відсотків від світового ринку золота. Це багато.
Це, звичайно, не половина і не 70 відсотків, як з іншими рідкісноземельними металами,
але це істотна частка.
Під заборону потрапили також ювелірні вироби з Росії. Це приблизно 15 відсотків
загального обсягу імпорту золота в ЄС. Збитки від цієї заборони
зазнає не лише Росія, але й Вірменія.
У золота в Росії як ювелірної продукції є одна цікава особливість
- Росія дуже рідко використовує своє дорогоцінне каміння.
Тому технічно заборона на імпорт російських ювелірних виробів вдарить,
наприклад, по Вірменії. Тому що 70% російських ювелірних виробів,
які експортують за кордон, містили вірменські діаманти.
А вірменський ринок діамантів сильно орієнтований на ринок російський.
Найбільше нові європейські санкції вдарять по великих золотодобувних
компаніях Росії, припускають аналітики. Таких у країні три.
Для російського бюджету загалом це менша біда, ніж попередні пакети санкцій.
Але санкційний тиск на економіку слід розглядати не в окремих галузях,
а сукупно, вважають експерти.
Звичайно, за своїм змістом, цей пакет слабший, ніж більшість попередніх,
тому що головним чином ідеться про золото. Поки це виглядає як менш
значуща річ, ніж це було, коли йшлося про нафту.
Тим не менше, тут важливо, що ЄС продемонстровав єдність,
а також поетапне посилення санкційного тиску на Росію.
Окрім золота, у новому санкційному пакеті ЄС є й персональні санкції.
Цього разу їх запровадили щодо мера Москви Сергія Собяніна,
президента мотоклубу "Нічні вовки" Олександра Залдастанова,
акторів Володимира Машкова та Сергія Безрукова. Загалом у цьому списку 48 осіб.
Коли йдеться про так званих селебрітіс, вони покликані продемонструвати
західному суспільству та світу, що Євросоюз має серйозні наміри.
Зрозуміло, що жодного впливу на те, що відбувається в Україні,
ці санкції дати не можуть.
Вони мають значення морально-психологічне і демонстративне, не більше.
Експерти додають, що нові санкції мають радше формальний характер.
Майже все своє золото Росія продавала у Великобританію.
Саме там знаходиться Лондонська асоціація ринку дорогоцінних металів,
своєрідна біржа-монополіст. А від покупки російського золота
там відмовилися ще у березні. Можна обійти санкції та продавати
російське золото безпосередньо до Китаю чи Індії. Але коштуватиме воно
там однозначно дешевше, впевнені фінансові аналітики.
Обійшовши лондонський агрегатор, назвемо його так, можна цілком собі
продовжувати торгувати. Швидше за все це навіть уже відбувається,
питання в іншому - в дисконті.
Приблизно розуміючи, що дисконт на ту ж нафту зараз - 20-30 відсотків марки Urals,
можна припустити, що відсотків 15 дисконт точно закладений у золоті,
що в цілому негативно відображається на надходженнях до бюджету,
враховуючи, що нині ціни на золото невисокі.
Як і яким чином російські компанії намагатимуться обійти санкції ЄС,
зрозуміти тепер буде складно. Нещодавно в Росії закрили доступ
до детальної інформації, якою звикли оперувати аналітики.
І тепер по всіх галузях - чи то газ, нафта чи золото - Центробанк РФ
публікує лише три види даних: загальну суму імпорту, експорту
та різницю між ними. Інформації про покупців російської сировини
та продукції, якщо такі з'являться, у цих звітах більше немає.